a lot of people have been calling me
asking me what it was like to get
manhandled by you yes my thing when we
when we arrest like that Mike after what
the [ __ ] are we doing people bringing
like dude what the [ __ ] man people love
it though they lie they like seen you
get beat up I loved seeing since they
like seeing a regular gay guy you know I
get get gorillas they like seeing a J
man taken down by a straight white man's
right hey yeah yeah you know my favorite
is the people are like too bad you can
do that in the UFC I'm like hey he'd do
it [ __ ] heads to G nobody could stop
your double like actually I didn't feel
bad about not being not being able to
sprawl because I don't think any we
brought was a couch to I think we did
break the couch no one was able to stop
your double your snappy double there no
cro cop Lavar Johnson Mitrione not even
that I prices shot I know Kara yeah I
just shot an Rothwell on the outside
just want to know for guillotine
purposes in the future did you add on
the outside hope you're studying tape
bro I did study it because you tap my
head and you go down and I should know
about euthanasia that's a [ __ ] I get
you thinking now that I know it you'll
now do those things I'm in the basement
you'll never you'll never fake my attic
you'll never fake it my attic and hit me
in the basement again
alright I'm just saying cuz I know it's
coming now okay dude see when you walk
into a room with a lot of black belts it
doesn't matter who they are I know in
your heart you go if I had to lock this
door everyone would die but dip it's
like boo Shesha
no not big guys just guys aren't big I'm
not talking about world-class
heavyweights yeah you have spoilers
hanging up your eyes huh yeah but I
don't want to ever hear you say about
any jiu-jitsu guy even if he when he's
145 150 160
I don't ever want you to say to me and I
don't want you say you say what are we
ever gonna be a gymnast I don't ever
want you to say publicly that that guy
could tap you know I don't have a I do
it you try to make yourself feel better
no he's your what you're crying no I'm
not an online
I know I know no I'm not doing that I
don't want you to say that it's gonna I
don't like [ __ ] humility you could
pull whoever it is hey please don't
bring up names find up I don't need find
any I know you know I'm not saying that
but your gorilla you're a gorilla you're
a bear to you you and any behind most
guys get logs most guys yeah belt dogs
to quote Ben even going to you even
great dogs even great dogs who are black
belt dogs you pull the head off their
spine so shut out to you yeah
yeah but my technique is deepening and I
have a heart I have a lion's heart and
when you have a lion's heart and your
technique is deepening sky's the limit
it's just that you're breaking down at
the same rate I am and I feel like we're
gonna get to a point do did your sense
they see that video it's very furious no
I haven't seen him but I train with him
tomorrow so let them know show them the
video and say what can I do better here
how did he say and then do that and I'll
see you on Wednesday we'll see how it
goes
I have I'm gonna send him the footage
I'm gonna get I'm gonna have tricks I
swear I'm gonna have tricks do it and
and know this I'm gonna have tricks that
are gonna sneak up on you and you're
gonna get caught so careful okay hey
this is this is a note for your future
your kill me right now hey you gonna
kill me right good but but but fit in my
future is looking bright careful okay
okay hey kid hey I want you to be dead
honest yeah for your birthday yeah did
you sense they give you a black belt I
didn't see him I was too busy by doing
not shooting it's in the mail I was too
busy he was a tribe's he was gone are
you a three striped black belt no not
yet he was gone he was gone but I will
have my honorary black belt I knew it in
no time because celebrity has to mean
something
Aston it's got to mean something this
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue Oh what's gonna happen what are
you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]